Paris McHale McHale this is Gary
Vaynerchuk god damn it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I told you this was last Monday morning
in your life
you
[Music]
should I call some people randomly right
now I always love that yes I was gonna
come in town regardless this weekend
they go to something what's your number
that's my tweet people just tweeting
their number I mean like a lot go cheer
tweet dude good afternoon good afternoon
Chad its Gary Vaynerchuk greevey a
humble leader you better [ __ ] believe
it man just sayin what's up I how you
doing I'm doing pretty good gay oh you
don't understand but ye my co-founder
man be like one whenever like [ __ ] sucks
but I do you know what we need to go
catch up on some Gary higher oh I
appreciate it man listen I hope you have
a great weekend you guys are in DC yeah
we're in DC my co-founder Steve is on
the line too
what I've seen what they're from New
York what's going on Gary's be all good
man thank you my man ah we were both
from New York uh yeah hey cut you off
set with Larry one one point of
contention I am NOT a Jets fan are you a
Giants fan I'm a Giants fan brother oh
sorry Steve literally our own
all right let's go to somebody else
hey guys it's gonna be a story they tell
forever
alright naejay time hello hey J hey
what's up
life is good how are you oh great that
what's happening skip pack Pennsylvania
what's happening Pennsylvania mr. Haas
man just got that coaches book kid the
basketball I love how they play we want
Mary gonna first of you do you like the
out what was the score we want my 20
actually it's crazy
I love it I love it a John Doe I know
that now how's everything going with you
ver life is good man just calling some
people and saying what's up and trying
to give some love I hope you have a
great weekend
yeah man you too take care you got it
ghost a term song-chun scott cones hello
Scott this is Scott this is Gary no way
how are you man oh my god you sound like
you I'm so I'm freaking out yes Scott
it's not this is not somebody tricking
you using my voice is me man how are you
so this is amazing
Scott I'm calling you to tell you that
you have 38 people that follow you and
you're following 38 people on Twitter so
now I'm following you so you have one
more follower than people you follow oh
[Music]
hey one more time designs knocking on
the pastor um what what should the
church be doing better you laying it on
to this um ah I meant why I gotta learn
learn from the best
well Scott are you an elf is reefing I
got do you think no one else is doing
well then you need to put out your
message not just within the four walls
of the church but throughout the four
walls of Earth right like look what's
happening right now you and I are having
personal collect connection this means
something and it's being done through
technology so use technology to
accomplish what you want whether that's
to raise money for kids that are
underprivileged whether that's to get
more people into the church whether
that's to sell baseball cards use the
technology that reaches people that is
current today do not be romantic about
how it was done before awesome thank you
thank you thank you Gary you're welcome
and I hope you have a great weekend you
came in have a good day bye bye Gary
just hung up on me because my [ __ ]
co-founder LL Cool J is a [ __ ] giant
this is true I'm just sitting here
randomly calling people on Twitter and
this happened to Chad Chad I'm sorry man
I loved you you can look at a second
everything lot more love somebody's
calling back
I know it's not uh Oliver yesterday this
is Gary Vaynerchuk hey Gary how are ya
tell me oh my god how you doing oh good
I'm doing good I mean I just had a
really bad day and your stuff you know
just get me fired up and well I love it
man I'm glum I'm glad that I I'm glad
we're connecting on a tough day you know
there's lots of them so I hope this
random thing brings a little bit of
happiness to you set you into the vision
in a good way
it's cool man we'll listen up I hope you
have I hope you have the best weekend
and I'm glad we had this moment you're
gonna keep us button oh well you two may
have figured out the top brother I can't
wait hurry up
Gary all right actually don't worry
[Music]
hello hello yeah this is Gary Vaynerchuk
shut your mouth it's me I thought I
would crazy you're not crazy I might be
crazy but you are definitely not crazy
holy [ __ ] Holy Mary thank you thank you
so much and Merry Christmas Steve how's
uh how's Dallas Texas he got a little
cold yeah listen I got it I want to call
a couple more people before I have to go
to this meeting and I hope you have a
great great weekend and I'm glad we got
to connect thank you thank you so much
you loving me just from the phone call I
love it good take care bye bye
never holy shoot yeah I was just another
say she held it together she's like holy
shoot and then she was invited
what somebody's calling people like
that's so ridiculous I hate when people
take good things and do bad things with
our arms what are we do in a day just uh
bringing some value scaling the
unscalable you know if Keyshawn Johnson
RAL tune called me randomly 20 years ago
I would have never forgot it
hello hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk mashita
you're kidding I'm not kidding
I'm not sure are you still there I'm not
kidding of course
oh my god how are you my life well I
mean it's pretty thank you so much how
how's it going okay now because I kinda
need a party to you well it's happening
we're talking
you wanting to do I will do anything
what what is work for you for free I
don't want your money I don't want
anything I just want to be anything well
you know what you should do then you
should send me an email we should talk
tell me what you I need you every day oh
I know exactly how I I know exactly who
you are I know exactly who you are
I'm I'm so glad we're connecting I would
be on your team I know that guy VI will
give you a kid I love it well I'll talk
to you soon okay yeah thank you
have a good night this is the point it's
so funny we're talking a little bit
about that and like I wish people up I
wish people actually knew I wish our
clients actually knew or people that I
do business with actually knew like
what's actually happening and like what
how easy it can be for me and how like
how no like how right I'm what I'm doing
is like people don't get it Dewey's e
this is now for me I could cruise into
the sunset like easily make lots of
money have a look yo Tim hey it's Gary
Boehner Jerry how are you doing good how
are you dude your beard is [ __ ]
unbelievable ha ha thanks man no worries
man how's life crazy how are you are you
in Denver yeah yeah I live live close to
Denver yeah awesome that's good good
well I appreciate you following my stuff
and putting out your phone number and
allowing me to say thank you for your
attention
oh yeah man I appreciate everything you
post man I mean it it's a the best
always a great way to use social media
again thanks man I appreciate it are you
a Broncos fan
ah you know you know give a [ __ ] about I
don't really watch a lot of football now
well can I get can you be a gel can be
it can you be a Jets fan man sure Oh
jump on the Jets man one at a time baby
yeah Timmy have a great weekend man
thank you so much for the love thanks
man thank you
talk to you good call every person hard
to make them a Jets fan when I buy the
Jets is what I'm due for the first four
years
this one's gonna be good yeah hello
hello this is Gary Vaynerchuk no solo
hey this is Gary Vaynerchuk Holy Smoke
Gary what a man holy [ __ ] what's up baby
oh my god Holy Smoke oh my god man I
think you want to figure out like how I
could just learn how to play Flynn
like I only feel like I've been doing
Twitter for a while and um and I've been
a bit like trying to figure out like how
much how I can make money I give love to
everyone I show everybody what I do all
the stuff that you say and it's like
people are never giving you up sometimes
they do I'm getting I'm giving you god
I'm giving you love right now
you did good dislike others shock I'm
like oh like who is this Carly to
California my god like diorite oh thank
you kind of I swear to god I'm in
Chicago right now dilated to I like I'm
gonna go on Twitter like Malay yoga
Gary [ __ ] just he caught like he called
me I Drive like I'm I'm in shock I Wow
yeah what's what's your name my name is
Jamal Jamal summer well Gary and I go
and I go by cams right I see that James
ride the by maybe hitting yeah they pick
you up 50 going on add James right they
were watch watch this Jamal everybody
watching this on dailyvee go follow jams
ride on Twitter that's real love Jamal
and vaynernation offer you in oh I
appreciate it so much late and I Jamal
real quick real quick cuz I want to call
a couple other people before I got to do
what I got to do you've got to have some
you gotta have something to deploy
against if you're gonna make money you
have to sell something that's the my
biggest mistake young hustlers make they
just think social media social media
followers don't mean anything you have
to have something to sell right so but I
don't sell anything personally I mean I
I mean well that's why nobody
giving you money help market other like
oh but you know like other products well
then listen then when I go to your
Twitter profile it can't go to level
next music calm it needs to go to a blog
that has you as a marketer that has a
$500 a day rate for marketing and social
media things like you got to put
yourself in a position to get the money
that you're looking for good on it so I
think that so I need to start a blog
that is that it's not that simple
you have to position yourself when
people find you on social when they
click that URL you're sending me to a
music site right yeah but well that's
because right because I mean that that's
our that's our record label now I need
to have a different so I need to have a
different URL if you if you want people
to hire you to do that that's where you
need to send them right now you're
sending them to music so that's how it
works out
you get attention you send them
somewhere you're now getting attention
from this engagement but you're sending
it to something different and I don't I
don't know I don't need a record label
so but maybe I needed somebody to help
me market my peaches shop for 500 bucks
for today and maybe it was Jamal but my
problem is I'm someone goddamn music
site hahaha preciate Baker no worries
ends need to figure out if there is
there like shouldn't like like you
suggest any like like certain blogs that
do that so like a starting point I think
you got to get a work a WordPress or a
Squarespace and create a a landing page
where people can see what you're
offering you got to just articulate what
you're offering make a medium post and
just write it in there tell them what
you're doing got it got it thanks I
meant goodnight you got a Peter Piper -
you wrote it take care of my man please
police they don't curse at first but the
second statement is straight fire hello
Nathaniel yes I think that's true my god
it's Gary Vaynerchuk oh my god how are
you can I call you Nate dude yeah call
me make that phone good how are things
they're great now I tell you what oh my
god
you know Nate you said that you thought
you were gonna regret putting out your
phone number
I think we've changed that and now I
think you're pumped you did it uh yeah
pretty touch I'm not gonna lie so what's
up man
gonna have to have to delete that tweet
though not staying out there that's for
sure go ahead no problem you do you how
are things
Chloe they're great Gary come ask you a
question of course so I tweeted out to a
couple of days telling you that you
inspired me to finally take on my first
freelance writing gig okay and I
actually completed that today and I you
know the the client gave me ten bucks
but she does me this one and a half star
review and didn't leave me any comments
or feedback I'm struggling to like jump
back from that you know well great then
I came to you at the perfect time [ __ ]
her hey meaning who gives a [ __ ] what
she said right like it's only one
customer there's plenty people who don't
think what I do is good or they didn't
like it like you know you're gonna
bounce back tomorrow we're going right
back at it and the next person's gonna
love it oh yeah and and more importantly
we're gonna go back at it tomorrow and
the next person's gonna leave a one-star
review and say you suck and we're gonna
go back at it the next day dude garyun
I'm just freaking out too much to like
you ain't keep talking to you anything
but like man that that pumps me up good
and I was reading my mentors an errand
Orndorff and Keith he was mentioned on
his blog something about let's get
rejected and that is like big slogan and
dude I hear you dude you accomplished it
you got rejected and you got paid that's
like a double win let's move on
ah gotta tell you my heart's racin
though but I let you go Gary and show
you what the other people in here can
get you my man I'm super glad we had
this moment together always remember it
let's move forward okay all right thanks
Gary take care pal man be careful this
is my favorite thing
hello Alex
yeah it's Gary Vaynerchuk oh my god how
are you what's up like I'm good how are
you what's happening I was trying really
hard for you to give you the calling it
worked I know it is which one didn't
work but when I replied on or the one I
just sent huge is not the one that you
just sent right now with the emojis with
the red phones oh dude awesome and what
do you like uh where do I live yeah in
Florida in Tampa nice man house Tampa
it's good it's cold today it's like 56
degrees the thesis is warm in Belarus I
know I know but I'm accommodated here I
get it all well I got a cold I didn't do
my heart like pumping out of my chest
right now like jeez some flattered man
well life is good what are you up to
what do you do what's your thing um yeah
I work full-time I go to school
full-time and I'm just hustling outside
of that I just got my school done so
right now I'm literally sleeping for
about 4 hours a day
and working for about 18 not even
talking to anybody not talking my
friends not doing anything I'm just
dedicated I'm focused and like almost
all that a lot of it do to you but it's
real well thank you man how's it going I
do I thought I stopped listening in
music I just listened to the daily be
all day to know why because I need to
get better at marketing I know it needs
to so and it's a huge help well good man
that's what that's what I'm doing it for
and it makes me happy and I'm glad
you're enjoying it man awesome I hope
you have a great get it yeah man keep at
it all right
all right thanks
guys it's so cool makeup looks great
oh thank you um faces Diana Harris Sarah
we have I go home
calling Lexi hello Xander speaking hi
it's Gary Vaynerchuk
holy [ __ ] how's it go Lexi
oh I've had better days Gary you know
but I'm keeping on truckin on doing some
remodeling in the house on a Friday
night in medicine Vlad can cram it makes
me super happy to call it a day that
isn't the best of all time I hope this
adds I hope this adds to swinging it in
the right direction for the weekend why
oh the one that hung up what happened
what happened he's just like I [ __ ]
everything up why my one shot I love
this all go brother I do appreciate okay
bro that was awesome he just called me
but to be honest I froze hello Paris
McHale McHale this is Gary Vaynerchuk
god damn it I [ __ ] knew it
here I don't hate one anything he did a
hidden phone number and all this [ __ ]
have you got my am I sent you over here
Chewbacca Mac from 1977 yes I did man I
did get it I we got it right it's in the
office right I saw that that's awesome
and I really appreciate it how are you
I'm [ __ ] great great like everything
the whole crush it all of it I doing it
it's awesome I can't believe I'm on the
phone with you that's awesome oh I
appreciate you got a good weekend
planned
have a great weekend actually I'm so
well-liked one of my clients are took me
to Palm Springs and I'm with their team
building Ching except this amazing spot
might dual houses and we went to like
vibration rooms and all the staff at mic
I'm sitting here I'm like this is my
[ __ ] job Saint Gary love you now dude
this is it this is you this is me for
about a second you took care of the rest
I think you're right on that to be
honest I love it man well listen I hope
you have the best weekend I'm glad we
had this moment I hope we cross paths
again I appreciate the Chewbacca Cup
yeah no worries man have a good one you
too take care bye bye
this is the best the initial reactions
such a high you might have to play we
may have to have a clip that just shows
this whole thing it's just maybe that
good cocoa butter poppy next oh yo its
Gary Vaynerchuk oh shoot
what's up my man I'm good at getting
some work done are you doing getting
some work done of course
Gary non-phone I appreciate the love man
thanks for paying attention enough to
put out your number of course any time
what are you up to what do you do I do I
see you're in Toronto so I do a lot of
old college like server work or
networking some appearance for small
businesses or other consumers good for
you man thank you
yeah man anything I can answer for you
well we got this moment Oh honestly I
wish I had a question like I know my
might focus on something else right now
oh no worries no worries I hope you have
the best weekend man a great holiday
we'll do an opinion you know of course
Gary of vaynermedia send it all right I
remember
all right back good dude hello Christian
yeah it's garyvee oh snap how are you
hello hello this is real life gave me
this is real life garyvee this is me
what's up
life is good man what's up with you
about the life is great I love it
where do you live I live in Chicago I
love it a lot of Chicago love I was just
in Chicago for like two minutes the
other day yeah hey Ivy give it up kid
without a care I know man I appreciate
it thank you for watching the show and
all the content oh oh wait thanks for
coming out of course man anything I can
help you with a real quick Oh will make
you will make you hustle harder every
day you know I'm just grateful you know
Christian like I'm just thankful do you
know that I don't know did you see all
these stats running around like it's it
the likelihood of being a human being is
440 trillion to one uh-huh that's really
yeah Google right now do you know how
hard it you you can win the Mega
Millions five times more likely than
actually becoming a human of course your
sperm is in your dad's nuts name
I don't well you just asked them clearly
hey Chrissy listen man I hope you have a
great holiday great Christmas great
whatever you know New Year's all that
stuff man and I appreciate the love you
all right man
take care
that's a great swimming from here a
[ __ ] London that's a quite like the
equivalent is like people leaving for -
women really give me a better idea -
call me Gary Gary how are things good
good man
thanks for putting out your number and
allowing me to say hello and thank you
for paying attention to my stuff thank
you really awesome thank you so much
they love GT my pleasure man what's
going on oh nothing just studying for
finals putting in work you country all
right gummy where do you live
brings my car for you very nice
I like your I like your snapchat filter
Twitter icon Cooper thank you you're
welcome man listen I hope you have a
great holiday and a great weekend and
don't study too much yes sir
all right man have a good night thank
you baby right all right
guys this one and this one in four
hundred trillion one in four hundred
trillion that's crazy this is what I've
been try to say Nate it is ridiculously
hard to become a human being and then
these [ __ ] complain it's your
one the greatest lotto and then by the
way let's get real more a little more
serious we live in America right I mean
there's a bunch of white dudes in here
and thank you for holding it down but
like like there's that like people are
not people are not quantifying their
luck and they complain about dumb [ __ ]
that's like winning the lottery like
three times here that's right he says
Farsi when you first Lausanne I thought
it was like you could be like a monkey
orale yeah that's all that's right oh
yeah yeah like that that's my thing the
whole tree like the Monday morning you
could have been a bus like I believe
that like not that I'm not confused I
know bus is not alive but a tree is that
step was my mom and a nap but you know a
dog is that sound makes no sense right
cuz it's great Nate literally back to
your dad literally your dad could have
gotten up real quick and got another
glass of water and that would have
changed the whole sequence of events and
you would not exist another last fall
your dad is extremely hydrated and has
enormous amounts of sperm who's gonna
get the last one let's go with this
really done and now and now understand
how awesome this all is how lucky are we
[Music]
so they've already won lottery yes
that's the poison people don't like and
the fact that you were like with me you
found a lot of me way more than you
think
no Danny I'm good man just calling some
peeps thanking them for paying attention
and giving me love oh man I appreciate
it that's amazing I got goosebumps right
now I appreciate it man
anything I can answer for you real quick
no I was the one that sent you the
picture I don't know if you remember I
tweeted you I got in a car accident the
other day and I said you were with me no
I saw that man I saw that you okay
yeah yeah everything's good it was my
wife's car and it's pretty much totaled
but yeah everything's good good man well
thank God it was your wife's car not
yours I'm just kidding yeah heaven
forbid right exactly well cool man I
wish you wish you luck in Missouri and I
hope you have a great weekend and great
holiday thank you sir I appreciate it
thank you much you're welcome the world
to me thank you my pleasure take care
bye right no it's a big deal this is my
whole like like I've never done right
and so now that you're like you feel
like you're being a little bit more
practical and data doubt and all this
stuff like real you realize how
ridiculous this is it's pretty crazy
your life has changed forever that's
interesting
no really I mean your life can yeah it's
how I think about it it's the only way I
think about it like what the [ __ ] is a
matter with people for sure I don't
think I don't think I don't know I don't
think they thought about it is
absolutely because I honestly think that
I'm here I don't think well that's the
punchline everybody takes for granted
what they actually have and my whole
point is the entire thing is what I'm
taking for granted super but that's what
I mean but that's easy in a micro in the
most macro it's you don't deserve to be
here
like and I like to use the word deserve
because like that makes it like look
it's ridiculous like it's ridiculous
though things ridiculous it's also human
nature for things like this and do not
pull it out the back that most people's
human nature yes of course that's why do
you think I'm winning yeah I've got my
[ __ ] in the right perspective and you
just go like once you realize it's all
gravy it gets real easy it's cool right
it is good man I'm pumped for you
something night for you yes we're ready
yo yo
it's Gary Vee what's up G how are you my
man hey man I'm good you remember me
I do yeah how are things I do I mean it
all her like he doesn't like you decided
to call me I saw you I was I was rapping
it up but I saw you in there is like you
know what let me just see what's up with
them have you been oh man I've been
fantastic man I'm here my two kids there
are three and seven right now and
starting the weekend man good for you
man I hope you have a great great
weekend and a great holiday and I'm glad
you put the number out so I can say
what's up again have you been I really
appreciate that I've been doing good man
I'm building a brand and I'm watching
the show and it's getting me high and I
really have no excuses man and I've been
following you since crush it I know and
I just really appreciate the hustle that
you good that you put in and the extent
to which this is what gets me man the
detail in which you document your life
is the most amazing thing I love half
garyvee but it for me dailyvee is flip
this test that's where the rubber meets
the road I appreciate it man well I hope
I hope you and the kids have a great
weekend and and I hope I get to see you
soon you will may I'll be in New York
soon all right man take care take
everybody fine he's a good dude but over
that one not as good as the one before
but we go with that one too but what's
the real one so the Knicks were always
ours I'll just watch the next I was like
all right
I can't do this anymore he's in her
interview with a Kyle Lowry on the
backhoe podcast oh I kind of like Kyle
Lowry yes I start watching the rafters
yes and that's it not not the same story
but it's pretty okay I mean yeah yeah
dude I'm like you probably with so much
stuff just watch it all of your content
I mean I don't you get it a lot but like
it feels these days the way that I that
I just look at life and the hustle
I tried thing it means a lot you know
what I do hear it and every time I hear
it it's like the first time I've heard
it means the world to me it's like it's
the best feeling ever
you can't you're you know I don't know
what else to say I appreciate it man
thank you yeah hey shadow tell her I
said hi
lose you know yeah done I will
is he Raptors fan now he's bandwagon in
sports so all right man I'll talk to you
later you know yeah thank good hello
Tori Anne oh my god it's Gary Vee
hey how are you I'm okay how are you
doing I'm okay what do you mean okay how
about your awesome or your super pumped
or something that gets me more excited
one of every four well I'm super pumped
that I'm on the phone with you that's
for 100% sure okay good
what do you got going on this weekend
I'm working I uh I don't know I'm doing
this job right now and it's pissing you
off right yes you've reached the 100
Perez if there's any questions I'll give
you bleep your name and number
thank you this could be good Ali it's
Gary Vee I tried you I'm really sad we
couldn't connect hope you have the best
day ever
that's gonna hurt what the boys fail
it's gonna hurt right um man it's bad if
that boy feels like it's Macho Man Randy
Savage Gary Vee she wants a hey wow I
loved him so much so alive she's alive
hello Gretchen yeah this is Gary
Vaynerchuk oh my god how are you I'm
good how are you I'm great you told me
to holla at your girl and I did
I'm so glad how are things in tennis are
you are you Nashville yes I am you got a
good weekend planned
um probably actually I'm I'm really
focused on my blog right now
good I love the hustle yeah I'm trying
that you're inspiring me good what do
you know
well thanks for being part of the
60-second Club thank you thanks for
calling no Reznick gonna have you have
another 60 seconds let's go okay all
right so um Josh where do I start I
started all the different media channels
I've really been focusing on Instagram
and sure one thing real quick and your
twitter is is linked to your blog
I would put it to your Instagram
the get healthy six one five I would
make that link to your Instagram if
you're really focused on Instagram I
would use the chess pieces to move it
all there and then amplify from there
okay okay I just follow I just followed
you on Twitter so I'll start seeing some
of your stuff Miguel said to chad saying
just hung up on me because my cocoa
powder miguel so that's funny you should
have picked up chad goes miguel i picked
up gary was chill until LL Cool J [ __ ]
the bed yes hola Jessica Gary how are
you I'm great how are you good what's
going on now much just got home from
work and how was that fantastic I like
it do so something I love and I wasn't
even working in TV a year ago and I've
worked on a TV show this year so that's
amazing
get it yeah you mentioned Empire in your
video the other day and I was like hell
yeah to the Empire I loved it
I appreciate you putting your phone
number out and giving me a chance to say
hello and thank you for paying attention
to my stuff Gary Vee oh shoot up man
what up man how are you so good baby
what's going on what's going on with you
I'm just about to go I skinny with my
lady y'all shout out Tyler Schmidt all
right that's the only reason you're on
man Schmidt made it happen
that's my guy right there man like a guy
like your best friend or I mean not just
the bull right there man okay treated
and well up there I'm treating him well
this is the greatest thing that has ever
happened this [ __ ] life yes it
does
did you Marie's daughter I'm actually
about to give him a pay cut cuz I don't
like his attitude
I'm kids I'm at your boy bro Maddie have
a great holiday man yeah these guys have
it go on get it get your ice skating
what's up Matt
ever Henry its Gary Vaynerchuk hey how
are you man
life is good I can actually see Smitty
was good oh oh all right let's go dude
this is all about Schmidt how's life hey
Matt I can't complain it all like a
drink no man I'm hungry he called my
love I'm just calling all Tyler's
friends and telling them how bad Tyler's
doing here Colorado to Facebook live
like two minutes ago and now it's your
turn man hey listen have a great holiday
all right are you doing man look crazy
am with you your sister look-alike I'm
just looking at it was like my god like
at school when she came over like this
is like do you know why all my Bujji has
you are Madeleine assistant is Luke at
the tone please record your message
when you finish recording you may hang
up EJ that's my second hey Luke so
listen here's my problem my work is on
fire and I need air conditioning so I
feel free to come back hey Luke it's
Gary Vee Trouty uh gave me your number I
just want to say what's up for all the
love hope your holiday is phenomenal I
hope I get to meet you soon come through
the office see ya my work is on fire
hello hello this is Gary Vaynerchuk
hi Gary Vaynerchuk
how are you Oh what's going on I am I am
I am good I am I'm fantastic
well good man thanks for giving putting
out your number and allowing me to say
what's up Wow ah man I have all your
book I appreciate
what's that there's gonna be one more
like 15 people I can't stop why would
you run to duty
I can't stop talking about forward for
telling people more I'm still super
strong off by day
did you know that you have the
probability of you being here's a one
four hundred trillion what in this room
yes no guys being born scary no no this
is real a little too it's real me my god
how we do Oh crazy thing like econ bus
yeah yeah you got it
yes she watches all right it's just true
no it's not crazy this is oh but the
numbers compound crazy hello hey it's
Gary Vaynerchuk how are you Patti how
are ya good what's going on not much
I was actually lucky YouTube videos and
I thought I would follow you on Twitter
and I saw your tweet sighs any remember
well I appreciate it it thank you to you
for calling me Patti I'm scared though
right now why your Dolphins fan aren't
you I am
Horace Miami so I am busy I know I know
all right well that's right it is what
it is I hope you have a great holiday
I'm glad we got to connect you the
doctor calling all right bye-bye
Hey that was fun that was a good set
that was fun I should do it way back in
the day on Ustream back in 2009 Phil
tried to get in and s recast and
spreecast calling people so fun it just
it's just great oh there's a really good
goddamn yeah and Gary the four hundred
trillion people saying just like not
people and not people
chances uh it's a crazy amount of hay
this Eliminator this is what I've been
trying to tell you and then I layer on
the fact that I wasn't born in America
so first of all was impossible then I
end up in [ __ ] Soviet Union right and
then after 80 years 60 years 77 you know
65 years of like Cold War hardcore
communism there's a moment in time that
allows me to leave Soviet Russia come to
America like like my you know what I'm
calling Joni because the odds of Johnny
getting this phone call were actually
zero he had no chance but now because
Nate kept sitting on this incredible
feeling he inspired me to call Johnny
and watch what happens
hello Johnny
yes sir it's Gary Vaynerchuk what's
going on man how are you I'm phenomenal
how about you I'm sitting here having a
drink with my fiance and a friend
well great by your tweet and thought I
throw it out there well I loved it it
worked
and Nate Nate here made me make this
call because he's so blown away that
it's one in four hundred trillion chance
of becoming a human that he's feeling
the glow and I stopped calling but I got
motivated I called one more person and
Johnny it is you that made that call or
got that call and I hope you have that
phenomenal phenomenal phenomenal holiday
we will man you too I hope things go
well with Xander and Misha and the wife
and everything
thank you very much done take care of
man good name with you you could care
less about your impact me I really
didn't care
he gave you zero point zero love sky
caught his reaction to the car and
that's all tick of the song you watch it
work you know amazing this would be for
us to look back at me no fun wow that is
incredible
how's it look great that's amazing
um
uh did you get that suit um you know fun
it would be if dailyvee was around for
the beginning yeah like the episode
where I told trout in middle of the
street he got inside life's future
or those episodes were filmed under
mining Nate's career he didn't set him
up for success me why aren't you that
able to do anything
Phil really wants a job back there's a
year to early yeah they put it on the
pile see just wanted to shout out good
you work and overcame all who usually
I'd lie above everything
no they treat me no I know that so it
was Maya it was right if you want to
throw that in there don't subscribe from
emails pretty carry so I know
thank you date alright alright hey guys
hi welcome thank you
we're ecstatic are we yeah seems them
nicely guys look nice yeah I'm Charlie
Charlie Gary how are you really nice to
meet you how are things is this is this
it so cool
you see the guitar it's cool right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]